quand un cinéaste expatriés film aux
états unis que film utile le rêve
américain
émir kusturika nous offre ainsi cette
semaine arizona dream avec faye dunaway
et jerry lewis et quand le cinéaste
expatriés est né à sarajevo à quoi
rêvent-ils retour et à la paix pascal
deschamps jean louis meule à nous
rencontrer
comme beaucoup de yougoslaves émir
kusturika s'est battu des années durant
contre le communisme
aujourd'hui il regarde impuissant à la
télévision son pays déchiré par les
nationalismes je me suis déjà trompé
tant de fois en essayant d'expliquer ce
qui se passe là bas je pense que ma
vision de la yougoslavie était trop
idéaliste à rêves
les rêves sont ce qu'il ya de plus
important dans la vie mais les miens
depuis un an et demi ne sont plus que
des cauchemars pour connaître les hommes
il faut connaître leurs rêves c'est donc
de rêve qu'il est question dans arizona
dream l'histoire d'américains ordinaires
qui poursuivent d'impossible chimère
pour échapper à l'ennui arizona dream
c'est en fait sa propre vision de
l'amérique
je ne suis pas allé là-bas pour
découvrir l'amérique
christophe colomb l'a déjà fait une fois
aux a suffi
je ne suis pas allé leur porter la bonne
parole ce film c'est simplement ma
vision de l'amérique
la vision d'un petit yougoslave qui a
vécu un peu là-bas et qui a été marquée
par toutes les choses très triste qui
s'y passe
les héros dans les zones a dream disent
à leur manière ce que vivent les hommes
depuis la nuit des temps toujours prompt
à s'emballer et comme toujours le réveil
est brutal
quel que soit le degré de civilisation
d'un pays quel que soit son niveau de
développement
même en amérique le pays quitte aller le
plus loin dans le progrès matériel et
technique
l'être humain reste tout petit confronté
à des choses qu'il ne maîtrise pas même
si vraiment tout savoir kusturika lui ne
veut pas désespérer il lui reste dans
ses valises posées pour le moment dans
la campagne normande un rêve celui de la
paix retrouvée en yougoslavie où il
s'est juré de tourner son prochain film